ryan day working hard to defend former
ohio state quarterback justin fields the
day began
with peter king's football morning in
america and he had quotes from dan
orlowski talking about
the storm of something other than sand
that happened last week when orlovsky
shared some things he was hearing from
teams that were negative about justin
fields
ryan day defending fields and i got no
problem
with ryan day defending his guy and i
love
the defense against the idea that justin
fields doesn't love football by pointing
to
what he did in that clemson game when he
got blown up
in the first half and went on to have
one of the great games of his career
and what he did to keep the 2020 season
on track when it was done when it was
gone when it was over they had to
resurrect
the 2020 season and justin fields was
the forefront of that
that's fine but don't use it as a
platform to take shots at the guys who
conscientiously sat the year out because
of concerns about the pandemic
whether it was their own health or the
health of their family members and for
ryan day to say and anyone out there
who wants to make excuses for ryan day
who wants to say well you have to
understand the full context of what he
said look he said what he said
and he didn't have to throw shade at the
guys who chose to opt out but he did
where was everybody else where were the
guys who were opting out then
you know you don't love the game if
you're doing something like that
that's what he said and i haven't seen
him say he didn't say it you know i was
concerned
because peter wrote the the story and
frankly i was a little surprised peter
didn't press
pause and say that's uncalled for by
ryan day
so i wrote it that's uncalled for by
ryan day
i was a little surprised ryan day didn't
try to say he didn't say what he said
sharing
yeah absolutely mike and he did go too
far and i appreciate him defending
justin fields although i think it came a
few days late but at the same time he
went too far there's no question about
that
you look at a guy like virginia tech
quarterback caleb farley who opted out
whose mom had had died and he was
concerned about his father's health and
didn't want to bring that home and had
several family members
with covid and and you're gonna to tell
this guy he doesn't love football
because he decided not to play last year
that's ridiculous
an ohio state study of all places ohio
state did a study and it included 26
male
and female athletes mike 30 of those
that that they tested had heart problems
after having coveted that was done at
ohio state so how you can sit there
after 550 000 people
in america have died of cover 19 and say
that it's just
unfathomable by the multiple to me that
anybody would think that
or say that yeah look i i agree
completely and i'm surprised sometimes
when
i i don't i don't know why it hasn't
been a bigger deal i don't
i thought when i wrote that story and i
pressed publish and i went back and
looked at it and i saw the initial
reaction i thought this is gonna be a
long day for ryan day and he deserved it
he made his bed
and i'm surprised it hasn't been a
bigger deal
for ryan day and maybe it's something
that just needs to take a little time
to sink in and people realize that it
was wrong but it was wrong it was wrong
for him to say that
i don't care how hard he was trying to
defend justin fields
it was completely uncalled for for him
to suggest
that the players who decided not to
fatten
his bank account by playing for free oh
wait i'm sorry
playing for tuition board room and
snacks the fair trade
for the billions that football players
generate they decided
to put their health and the health of
their family over not getting paid to
play football
and they get called out by ryan day
i kind of like the fact that he showed
who he is
and frankly now you know it's i was
going to get on a soapbox and say hey if
i had a son
or a nephew or a cousin or whoever who
was thinking about where to go play
major college football that would be a
factor but then i would take a step back
and say you know what
they're all that way he's just the one
who accidentally said the quiet thing
out loud shireen
yeah no question mike and you think
about what players give up to play
high school football college football
pro football you get paid for it but
it's broken bones
and it and it's the risk of torn
ligaments and it's the risk of
lifelong brain injuries and everything
else that goes along with football
career threatening injuries and these
guys put it all on the line when they go
play for nothing
else other than as you said room board
and some snacks along the way
at least legally as as the ncaa allows
it right now
but these guys put it on the line to
think that they don't love football it's
just ridiculous
and to opt out that they don't love
football is even more ridiculous
we talked about this last week in
the context of the reckoning that the
ncaa is currently facing
in the u.s supreme court tyrone prothrow
tyrone pro throw
career-ending injury while playing for
free for alabama
could have gone on to play in the nfl
could have been a great player could
have made millions of dollars working at
a bank there was a
i don't know if it was on real sports
with brian gumbel somebody did a a look
at
tyrone pro throw long after the fact
never got to have that career why
because
he risked his health to go play college
football because
he doesn't have any other alternative
the nfl and the nfl pa
forced you to go for three years and go
play college football and he suffered a
serious injury
what was really there for him so that's
what we're talking about
and in this case whether it's concern
for their own health
concern for a family member's health the
idea that guys opted out
means they don't love football is bull
crap sorry even though there's plenty of
profanity there peacock i gotta take
this up with somebody
a lot of movies with profanity a lot of
tv shows with profanity i can't drop an
s bomb once in a while
i don't know how i feel about that but i
prefer to remain employed so i won't
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports